it was a symbolic vote and one easily
approved by the Democrat held House of
Representatives but for Republicans and
one independent also supported the
motion to condemn Donald Trump for
making xenophobic statements we condemn
their hurtful and offensive comments
that demean immigrants and people of
color these comments from the White
House are disgraceful and disgusting and
Vic's comments are racist how shameful
to hear him continue to defend those
offensive words words that we have all
heard and repeat not only about our
members but about countless others we
are America America is a nation of
immigrants
we are not going anywhere America is our
home and many of us will still be
standing here long after the occupant of
over office leaves earlier this week
Trump released a series of tweets
attacking progressive female Democratic
politicians saying they should go back
to their countries his unnamed but
understood target for outspoken
non-white lawmakers all US citizens
Trump is standing by his comments they
can leave they can stay but they should
love our country and they should work
for the good of our country senior
Republicans are supporting their leader
and I think the tone of all of this is
not good for the country following the
vote of condemnation Texas Democrat Al
Green introduced articles of impeachment
against Trump saying the president was
unfit for office another symbolic move
unlikely to succeed